brincan dijo que se presentaba en nueva
york' en nuevo para empezar una guerra
sino para evitarla dijo que aunque rusia
está diciendo que está sacando las
tropas de la frontera inteligencia
estadounidense ve barcos aviones y
tropas acercándose aún más a la frontera
con ucrania y dijo que un ataque podría
darse en los próximos días sin embargo
no presentó pruebas para esto y tampoco
presentó pruebas sobre el argumento de
que moscú estaba preparando alguna
pretexto para llevar a cabo el ataque
contra ucrania al respecto también el
secretario de defensa lloyd austin dijo
que se están sumando equipos militares
rusos en la frontera dijo que se está
sumando también provisiones de sangre y
que esto no se hacía precisamente cuando
una fuerza militar se está retirando de
algún lugar alguna zona américa